c'est l'un des téléfilms les plus
attendus de l'année le biopic sur l'ex
gagnant de la star academy mort de la
mucoviscidose à 23 ans grégory lemarchal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fiction qui sera diffusé sur tf1
cette année a pour titre pourquoi je vis
un clin d'oeil à la chanson de balavoine
que grégory avait magistralement
interprété sur le plateau de la star ac
[Musique]
l'acteur qui prend les traits du
chanteur se nomme michael lumière et
d'après les personnes qui ont assisté au
tournage la ressemblance avec grégory
lemarchal est frappante
j'ai travaillé en observant
attentivement ses postures et j'essaye
de les reproduire au mieux les parents
de grégory lemarchal était sur le
tournage afin de s'assurer que le film
et l'interprétation de michael lumière
ne porterait pas atteinte à la mémoire
de leur fils cette fiction se veut la
plus réaliste possible
on retrouvera l'animateur de la star
academy nikos aliagas dans son propre
rôle
on est toujours dans le voyage est bien
que la production n'est pas pu tourner
dans le célèbre château de dammarie les
lys
ils ont jeté leur dévolu sur une bâtisse
quasi semblables et les décors de
l'époque ont été refaits à l'identique
bref tous les ingrédients seront là pour
nous replonger dans le monde féerique de
la star academy et de son petit prince
grégory lemarchal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de l'a 13 heures
mais de savoir voilà un gros bisou alors
alors c'est un événement je trouve ça va
faire un véritable carton
alors j'ai une question parce que nikos
aliagas très justement reprend son rôle
mais pourquoi karine ferri n'a pas
repris son ouïe est ce que ça te
rappelles-tu qu'elle soit d'abord
vraiment animatrice avant d'être
comédienne voilà moi je trouve que
honnêtement je pense qu'on ne lui a pas
proposé tout simplement je pense que si
la proposition avait été faite à karine
ferri elle aurait bien évidemment
accepté personne ne refuse de jouer dans
un film qui va clairement car ce n'est
pas sûr elle a été sa fiancée c'est pas
sûr pour elle c'est trop douloureux de
jouer ce rôle-là afin de recommencer a
créé c'était pas un rôle ils ont une
vraie relation
mais là il est évident que tf1 surfe sur
l'émotion la disparition de ce garçon
que tout le monde a aimé
donc forcément hop on sort une série bon
alors là dit est très compliqué alors
j'aimerais savoir
je vais demander à frantz fanon est ce
que quand on compte tours on connaît un
peu ce qui s'est passé sur le bateau
moi j'ai effectivement quelques bruits
de coulisses était extrêmement compliqué
pour grégory cités contre est
contraignant parfois c'était voilà
c'était des moments très très très
compliqué et ce que vous pensez qu'ils
vont tout montrer ou est ce qu'ils vont
forcément et du corps et le propos je
sais pas s'ils vont tous le montreux
j'espère pas je pense pas que ce soit
nécessaire de tout montrer non plus
parce que les gens une image de grégory
qui monterait sur scène il montrait
l'image d'un gars sont forts ils
montraient pas forcément ses fêlures et
ces moments un petit peu plus compliqué
je vois pas l'intérêt non parce que ça
passe le couple est ce que moi j'ai su
semble sur le l'histoire de d'adressé
que pour lui elle est sur scène et se
préparer pour chanter c'était une
véritable souffrance hier que c'était
vraiment un effort surhumain
j'espère qu'on va aller au delà c'est de
montrer quand même puisque à quoi sert
ce feuilleton mais tous ici tout est
tous égaux face à votre question mais
c'est beaucoup il avait beaucoup de mal
quand on faisait du sport et dans la vie
de tous les jours mais quand il chantait
c'était comme l'âme c'était comme
magique c'est à dire qu'il ne toussez
plus et là il avait une puissance dans
la voix et c'est comme s'ils étaient
plus malade il était voilà c'était un
chanteur comme les autres est mille fois
plus talentueux que tous les autres
moyens un truc sur cette idée de biopic
qui me dérange profondément j'ai
l'impression qu'on nous a volé notre
histoire et qu on la raconte sans nous
en fait et et voilà pour moi grégory
c'est grégory ça peut pas être quelqu'un
d'autre
qu'il joue c'est trop récent c'est
encore lui cessons vie
âge mois le voir jouer par quelqu'un
d'autre et faire un biopic je vois pas
l'intérêt en fait faire un documentaire
sur grégory où tu restes non mais où tu
raconte ce qu'il a vécu bête ou leur
fais tu fais l'appel aux dons pour
l'association grégory lemarchal
saint-just intéressant mais faire un
biopic avec des acteurs qui ressemble un
peu à grégory pour raconter une histoire
qui ne ressemble un petit peu je vois
pas du tout ça mais maladie à quelques
semaines de la star ac ont été repris
mais pas le vôtre non mais moi mon
personnage à la star qui n'a aucun
intérêt à jouer la question est ce que
ça vous dit est ce que ça vous pèse un
peu de paille avoir été appelé pour eux
n'ont même pas de danger par les
blessures non non non non pas là pour
moi ce qui me dérange c'est de voir grec
joué par quelqu'un d'autre que greg
barème de fer et profitez en c'est pour
ça que le principe du biopic
il me dérange en fait il voulait me met
mal à l'aise pour moi c'est trop récent
ceni donc l'amour pour vous c'est pas un
bon film mais c'est quoi la môme c'est
pas un bon fils à combien d'années après
grégory c'était y'a 15 h et à 15 h
choisi la star ac avec lui une star vous
rigolez ou quoi là c'est un truc est
tout récent grigory de celle ci c'est
une histoire qui est encore vivante pour
nous qu'il est encore la fin on peut pas
pour moi ce biopic voilà ça met mal à
l'aise c'est votre droit votre google
est une icône grégory lemarchal pour
plein de gens pour pour notre génération
nous les trentenaires entre 30 40 ans
pour les gens qui sont malades de cette
mucoviscidose qui le voient comme voilà
qui l'ont vu comme une force qui a donné
l'espoir à plein de monde
moi je trouve que quinze ans c'est le
temps qu'il faut effectivement c'est
largement suffisant et que justement
aujourd'hui mérite d'être mis à
l'honneur le l'acteur qu'ils ont pris
pour jouer son rôle qui est michael
lumière est un dieu vivant de la comédie
il est juste extraordinaire il lui
ressemble il est humble il est gentil il
a rencontré ses parents il a été
maintenant que tu dis ça mais ça peut
pas cuisiner plus la série donc cesser
pas tu peux pas mettre lui dans un bain
messieurs les intervenants bio venus en
cars moment donné c'est 15 ans est
largement suffisant voilà et pour ça
allait revenir à karine karine ferri
capable après la pression comptable oui
il ya deux choses que je trouve
extrêmement dérangeante là je rejoins de
francesca c'est qu'une espèce de
business où on tire la ficelle sur le
dos de grégory lemarchal que je ne
connaissais pas donc voilà ça c'est plus
à toi de nous le dire est une autre
chose c'est que beaucoup de personnes se
sont créés une notoriété sur son dos et
ça c'est quelque chose qui me dérange et
à qui je peux pas citer non parce
qu'aujourd'hui on sait
les pompes ou pas mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui français que je pense
qu'on pense à beaucoup de gens en commun
et malheureusement les vraies personnes
qui l'ont vraiment connu côtoyer pour
les vraies valeurs se préfère se mettre
en retrait par pudeur mais
qu'aujourd'hui on a beaucoup qui profite
d'un mental qui est l'ami des stars est
ce que ce en deux oui le rapport est
l'ami des stars
est-ce que vous ça vous choque qu'on
fasse un biopic sur la sorgue et
d'horribles sur d'autres personnes et
non pas du tout je crois que non non moi
ça me choque pas d'autant plus comme tu
l'as dit mika lui mérite un très bon
acteur qu'on avait vu dans la vérité si
je mens 3 on avait d'ailleurs reçu
mais au-delà de ça au delà de ça je
crois que c'est une très belle histoire
sur le courage et que je crois que ça
peut aider beaucoup de gens qui traverse
cette épreuve de la mucoviscidose et les
parents et les familles et tous en pc
avec la corde et récolter des dons alors
qu'ils aident ils vont le faire sur les
routes